you posted a video for Oprah's birthday
and I think this is this you partying
this is partying you partying with
Oprah's yeah house it was her house a
birthday recently I've done that too
anyway let's take a look you know what
is tell us what it's like people want to
know such a fascinating figure it's just
so many people and and well to everybody
and people feel like they know Oprah but
tell us what's it like to party with her
what would people know what might
surprise people about Oprah well the
fact that she sings 50 cent yeah there's
something about it you probably don't
know but no she is one of the most
precious precious people in the world
and people know that but speaking of my
my dad and this is actually a story I've
never actually told publicly my mom was
really quite ill a few years ago and
Oprah knew about this cuz I talked to
her about it and she was on her way to
South Africa to to her Leadership
Academy to see her her girls down there
and she stopped off in London without
telling me called me from the hospital
having found out where my mum was she
went so you're going to see my mom
that's incredible and my eye then had to
call my dad I was filming in Maine said
Oprah is at the hospital daddy get there
right now he's in he's in traffic so
Oprah is sat in the lobby for an hour
and a half waiting for my dad doing
selfies yeah you know having her
bodyguard get a sandwich was she swayed
for my dad and and yeah and she until
she saw my mom she didn't leave that's
fantastic yeah that's just an incredible
story yeah yeah that's
I just loved it
the part that comes to mind is that yeah
Oprah was there with your mom and your
dad is off driving around no he's in
traffic that the funniest thing was I
was on the phone with her and I was
going you're in the lobby right now oh
yeah oh hold on hold on what did happen
Oh selfie yeah I think that's her life
that's when she gets up in the morning
goes to the bathroom there's like three
people there waiting for a selfie yeah
yeah probably did did she
there's been a lot of speculation that
she might run for president in 2020 has
she said anything to you about that yes
and the answer is no yeah I've been
pretty emphatic about yeah yeah yeah no
she she couldn't think of anything worse
yeah and to be honest I do think it's
the toughest job in the world I wouldn't
wish it on my worst enemy let alone
someone I like yeah yeah that's a tough
job yeah tough to do it well as we can
see
you